I'm excited for this conversation
because I consider you to be really
intelligent um but I feel like sometimes
there are ways that conservatives talk
about certain issues that seem to defy
logic and reason I guess so here and I'm
sure you feel the same way about prog I
feel same about progressives um but even
some uh liberals for sure uh before I
ask this question it's going to relate
to education we can agree broadly
speaking that statistics are real and
that not everybody could do everything
so for a grounded example
uh my life was pretty bad I got into
streaming and I turned my life around
and that was really cool but I can't
expect everybody to do what I did right
like everybody being able to join the
NBA or to be like a streamer of course
everybody has different qualities sure
okay so I used to be a lot more
libertarian um when I was 2021 and one
of the things that dramatically changed
kind of my view on government uh
manipulation of things in the I guess in
society came uh when it came time to
deal with my son and the school that he
went to and one of the things that I
noticed was when it came time to send my
son to school I could either do private
education or I could do public uh
personally I did 12 Years of Catholic
private education um however the public
schools in Nebraska depending on where
you lived were very very very good and I
opted for a certain District I bought a
house there I moved there and then my
son was able to go to those schools um
and he's been going through those
schools and the difference of
availability of like technology like
these kids are taking home iPads and
like first grade uh they've got like
huge computer labs and everything do you
think there is some type of I don't want
to say Injustice or unfairness because
I'm not even looking at it that way just
pragmatically that there might be
children that are in certain schools
that if they just had better funding or
more uh access to Technologies or things
available to them that those kids would
become more productive members of
society that with like a little bit of a
help they they could actually achieve
more and do better for all of society so
I think that on the list of priorities
when it comes to education the
availability of technology is actually
fairly low on the list of priorities
sure things I've heard are food
availability and I think air
conditioning I think are the two biggest
ones that I hear but sure well I mean
the biggest thing in terms of Education
itself not just the physical facilities
that we're talking about would actually
be two parent family households sure
communities that that have fathers in
them is actually the number one decid s
according to Roland frier and many
studies done on this particular topic
and the idea that that money alone that
investment of resources is the top
priority in schooling is boted by the
fact that LAUSD which is where I went to
school when I was younger they pour an
enormous amount of money into La USD
we're talking about tens of thousands of
dollars very often per student and it
does not result in better schooling
outcomes and so when you say if we could
give every kid an iPad would you give
every kid an iPad the question is not if
I had a replicator machine from Star
Trek would I give everybody an enormous
amount of stuff sure I I would every
every resource is fite every resource is
limited and you have to prioritize what
are the what are the outcomes that you
seek in terms of the means with which
you are seeking them
and so again I think that the question
is is I quibble with the with the
premise of the question which is that
again the the chief Injustice when it
comes to education on the list of of
injustices is lack of availability to
technology or that it's a funding
problem I I just don't think that's the
case sure and I can half agree with you
there but I don't think any amount of
changes in the schools will create two
parent households right we can't bring a
back I totally agree with you that's why
I think that the the fundamental
educational problem is not in fact a
schooling problem I think that pre-exist
that sure but then I feel like we're now
I feel like this is kind of the
conservative marry around where it's
like what can we do to help with schools
so two of the things that I've seen I
think that are usually brought up in
research is one is air conditioning that
children in hotter environments just
don't learn as well um and then the
second one is access to food so like
kids that are given like a breakfast or
a lunch that's provided at school like
increases educational outcomes now I
agree that neither of these things might
be determinative in like well 20% of
kids were graduating and now 80% of kids
are graduating or these kids are all
going you know from with their geds into
the workforce and now these kids are all
suddenly becoming Engineers but in terms
of where we can help do you think there
should be like some minimum threshold or
minimum Baseline of like at the very
least every school should have a non-
leaky gym or every school should have uh
if children can't afford lunch or
breakfast like some sort of food
provided or every school should have
these like Baseline things so again I'm
going to quibble with the premise of the
question because I think when it comes
to for example food
insecurity School food programs again
you can always pour Mone into any
program and at the margins create change
I mean there's no doubt that pouring
money onto anything will create change
in a Marginal Way the question is how
large is the margin and how big is the
movement right so the Delta is what I'm
looking at and so I think that the
you're you're starting at a second order
question which is what if we ignore what
I would think are the big primary
questions of Education namely family
structure value of education at home how
much you have parents who are capable or
willing to help with homework what are
the incentive structures we can set up
for a society that actually facilitate
that how local community take ownership
of their schools is a big one right all
of these issues we're ignoring in favor
of say air conditioning or lunch
programs and so in a vacuum if you say
air conditioning and lunch programs
sounds great in a vacuum in in terms of
prioritization of values and cost
structure are those the things that I
think are going to move the needle in a
major way in terms of public
policy I I I do not and in fact I think
that many of them end up being
disproportionate wasts of money I mean
I've talked before pretty
controversially about the fact that an
enormous amount of school lunch programs
are out like an enormous amount of that
food ends up in the garbage can is there
a better way to do that if there is a
better way to do it then I'm perfectly
willing to hear about that better way to
do it but it seems to me that one of the
big flaws in the way that many people of
the left approach government is what if
we hit every net with a hammer and my
question is what if the Gat isn't even
the problem what if there's a much
bigger substructure problem that needs
to be solved in order to if you're
shifting deck chairs on the Titanic sure
you can make the Titanic slightly more
balanced because the deck chairs are
slightly better oriented but the real
question is the the water that's gaping
into the Titanic right yeah and I agree
with you 100% but again that I feel like
we're on the conservative merry gound
then of never wanting to address not a
conservative Mound I can I can give you
10 ways well sure but so like here would
be the merry go round I would say that
like there's a minimum funding for
schools that I think would help children
and then we go well the thing that would
help them the most is two parent
households and I go okay well two parent
households actually aren't the problem
um the issue is access to things like
birth controls that people don't have
children early on and it's like but the
issue isn't actually birth control the
issue is actually you a certain amount
of money to move out early and to get
married and then to have a two parent
household so it's actually like Economic
Opportunity well it's no just two parent
households yeah but like what is the
what are the pre people and have
babies sure done that's great we can say
that and try to fight against you know
however many hundreds of thousands of
years of human evolution but people will
have sex and people will make babies and
then they used to get married the vast
majority of people in this country with
kids used to be married the vast
majority of people with kids in this
country now are not married increasingly
that obviously a societal change
something changed it was human evolution
but a lot of those things in terms of
resting on whether or not people get
married have to do with financial
decisions do you have the money people
are worse off now than they were 50 60
years ago and the marriage rates were
higher people are delaying the start of
their careers because education is going
increasingly important so in in other
words people are richer now and they
have more education now and yet they're
having more babies out of wedlock now
because they're richer and have more
education I'm saying that the one of the
biggest indicators for whether or not
somebody's willing to get married is how
much money both people are making if
they can move out of their household
people don't tend to want to get married
at 22 when they've just finished College
when they don't have the money to move
out and they can't house because we have
changed the moral status of marriage in
the culture meaning that everyone poor
Rich and in between used to get married
that is by the way a huge percentage of
marriages in the United States used to
be what they would call shotgun
marriages meaning that somebody knocked
somebody up and because they did not
want the baby to be born outside of a
two parent household they would then get
married do we think that shotgun
marriages though are a way to bring back
equilibrium to education that if we yes
absolutely yes 100% a child deserves a
mother and a father because that is the
basis for all of this including
education do we think that shotgun
marriages are are well let's say this do
we think that that's a reasonable
direction that society would ever take
or is this like yes it was the
reasonable direction for nearly all of
modern history was but history Moves In
One Direction right why because of time
I mean people people don't think that's
a in in what in what ways is and I don't
think we've ever like regressed social
standards back to like oh well let's go
a 100 years back and do things that you
know used to exist before I where the
entire left right now is arguing that we
regress social standards by rejecting Ro
versus Wes and that's obviously not true
the Rover verse weight is not a social
standard it's a Supreme Court ruling
number one number two what if you read
the ACT majority of opinion on roie Wade
we can see that socially we ever
actually never made huge progress on how
Society viewed abortion this has always
been an incredibly divisive thing right
even that was I think part of Al's uh
writing on it was that things like gay
marriage for instance we've kind of
moved past and it's not really as
debated anymore but abortion was never a
settled topic Des The Arc of History
constantly Moves In One Direction is be
lied by nearly all of the 20th century
what do we mean by that I mean I
mean barbarism communism Nazism all of
that was a regression from what was
happening at for example the beginning
of the 19th century in the 20th century
what in what way Nazism and communism w
a regression from what was going on
these are well in terms of like
communism being a regression for
instance I'm not a communist but like
the industrialization of the Soviet
Union happened under a communist Society
the industrialization murder of tens of
millions of people consider that a
regression moral regression which is
what we are talking about now moral
regression and you're you're suggesting
that moral regression I wouldn't term a
return to Traditional Values a moral
regression you would but your suggestion
is that history only Moves In One
Direction and I'm suggesting that
history does not only move in in One
Direction it tends to move actually back
and forth sure I don't think that all of
history moves in one uh One Direction
there are going to be Wars there are
going to be times of peace I think in
general we're more peaceful now than we
have been in the past but I think when
we look at the way that people live
their lives I think that we tend to move
in a certain direction socially so when
it comes to things like racism or when
it comes to things like slavery or
women's rights I think that there are
two huge things that probably aren't
changing in the US and one is access to
contraception and one is women working
jobs I think that these two things are
probably huge things that are moving us
off of shotgun marriages or getting
married very early on and I don't see
though do you think that those two
things are going to change fundament
first of all what the data tend to show
is that actually more Highly Educated
people as you were saying tend to get
married more so the idea is that women
getting an education somehow throws them
off marriage it's the opposite
usually but those women aren't getting
shotgun marriages those women aren't
having children now you're Shifting the
topic my my topic was how to get more
people married and what I'm s and and
then you suggested that higher levels of
Education are delaying marriage and
making it less probable and what I'm
telling you because this is what the
data suggests is that actually as you
raise up the the educational ladder
people tend to be married more than they
are lower down on the educational ladder
if you're a high school graduate you're
less likely to be married than if you're
a postdoc I agree with you but that's
because one of the biggest precursors to
getting married is having like a level
of economic stability so as people get
more educated they obtain this economic
stability and then they're in a more
comfortable position to explore more
serious relation there's another
confound there I mean the confound is
that
people in stable marriages tend to be
the children of stable marriages and
there's only one way to break that cycle
which is to create a stable marriage and
that is something that is in everyone's
hands again this notion that it is
somehow an unbreakable unshatter barrier
to get married and have kids I don't
understand where this is coming from why
is that such a why is that such a
challenge chall I it's unbreakable or
unshatter I was just the initial point
was for school if we can provide a
minimum level of educational stuff for
children that probably be good but when
we Retreat back to well it has to be the
families that are fixed first fixing
families is a multivariate problem many
I fine within my local community we all
vote again I I've suggested that there's
a difference between local community and
federal I'm fine with my local community
voting for school lunches or air
conditioning or whatever it is that we
all agree to do because the more local
you get the more homogenity you get in
terms of interest and the more interest
you have in your neighbors all of that's
fine I'm part of a very very solid
community in our community we give to
each other we have minimum standards of
helping one another all that's wonderful
when it comes to the actual problem of
Education what I object to in the
political sphere and this happens all
the time is everybody is arguing on top
of the iceberg about how we can move the
needle five percentage points as opposed
to the entire Iceberg melting beneath
them and we just ignore that we pretend
that that's just you know sort of the
natural consequence of thing the Arc of
History suggests that people are never
going to get married again well I mean
actually what the Arc of History
suggests realistically speaking is that
the people who are not getting married
are not going to be having kids and what
it also suggests the people who are
married are going to be having kids and
so the demographic profile actually over
time is rather going to shift toward
people who are having lots and lots of
kids I'm married I have four kids
everyone in my community is married
that's like minimum buying in my
community is four kids okay and so
what's happening actually in terms of
demographics is that the people who are
more religious and getting married are
having more kids and so if you're
talking about the Arc of History
shifting toward I I would suggest that
actually demographically over time long
periods of time not over one generation
over long periods of time the only cure
for low birth rate is going to be the
people who get married and have lots of
kids yeah I don't necessarily disagree
with any of that but I'm just saying
that
again on the on yoursite when I bring up
the term marry around um I think that
there are good conversations to be had
about people getting married um because
stable families produce stable children
that are less likely to commit crime
that are more likely to go to school
that are more likely to be productive
members of society ET Etc I'm not going
to disagree with you on any of that all
of that is true um it's just frustrating
that sometimes when you bring up any
problem all of it will Circle back to
other things that makes it seem like we
can't make any progress in any area
without like fixing way I mean I
literally just told you that on the
local level I'm fine for people voting
for so for instance on the local level
so for school funding school funding is
done I think generally per District so
what do you do when you have poor
districts that can't afford air
conditioner for their schools I mean the
idea there would be that presumably if
the society meaning the state and I
generally don't mean the federal state I
mean like the state of California for
example decides that everybody ought to
have air conditioning people will vote
for air conditioning and that's
perfectly legal and I don't think
there's anything morally objectionable
about that per se I also don't think
that that's going to heal anything
remotely like the central problem and I
think that what what what tends to
happen terms of government is people
love arguing about the problems that can
be solved by opening a wallet and nobody
likes to solve a problem by you know
closing their sex life to one person for
example or having kids within a stable
religious community like the things that
actually build
Society I'm fine with arguing about each
of these policies and and whether we
apply them or not is a matter generally
of pragmatism not morality it's a matter
of incentive structures not per se
morality because incentive structures do
have you know moral underpinings there
there's such a thing as you know for
example if you're going use a welfare
program you have to decide how effective
it is to what crowd it applies where the
cutoffs are does it disincentivized work
does it not all of these are pragmatic
concerns but on a moral level the
generalized objection that I have to
people on left side of the aisle is that
they like to focus in these
conversations very often it feels as
though it's a conversation with with
people who are drunk searching under the
the lamp for their keys the problems
they want to look at are the problems
that are solvable by government and then
all the problems they don't want to look
at which are the actual giant monsters
lurking in the dark and not particularly
solvable by government are the ones they
want to ignore and assume are just the
natural state of things and I don't
think that's correct at all and I one
billion perent agree and then obviously
my criticism for the conservative side
is the exact opposite where where there
are Parts where government could remedy
some issues um for instance you know uh
children having sex with each other and
producing other children out of wedlock
like sometimes having after school
programs is nice to prevent that like I
didn't have time for these things when I
was in school I was doing football
practice I was doing Cross Country
Practice I went in early for a band you
know um I agree with you that sometimes
people only focus on one end of the
problem as a I hate to be that guy um
but as somebody that have you ever
watched The Wire sure I'm not going
toite the wire as real life example but
like obviously there's only so much you
can do in a school When the Children
coming in are so beyond destroyed
because of the family life and
everything prior to them even getting to
school that day so I agree government is
not like the solution to Broken families
that would never be the case and it's
actually not the solution to education
depending on the kind of solutions that
you're talking about some solutions yes
some solutions no yeah the only thing
I'm looking at is as I said earlier just
like these minimum threshold things
where it's like where can government
make because you mentioned marginal
which I think is a really good way to
look at things there's marginal cost and
marginal utility to things where the
first $1,000 per student you spend might
give you a huge return but the extra
20,000 after I these are all pragmatic
discussions actually this is what we
used to hash out in legislatures before
they turned into platforms for people
grandstanding but yes sure okay
yeah
I